the entire time you'll be able to see
the reflection of the light in these
sunglasses so Tryon saying that I'm here
to point things out that'll probably
bother you men and black international
too many black international is the
newest and fourth men and black movie
stars Tessa Thompson and Chris Hemsworth
long story very short
Tessa Thompson's character comes across
MIB headquarters and they're like all
right you're hired a probational basis
so she partners up with Chris Hemsworth
from another MIB branch hence
international now we have men in black
international I don't never lie to you
many black international carries the
torch pretty well for a while and Chris
Hemsworth was first story all right he's
the pretty guy he's the guy dudes
wannabe this times gone on we're like no
no he's actually really funny he has
good comedic timing and he totally shows
it in here I like that it wasn't just a
rehash in that sense you know it's not
like you have the old seasoned one
taking the young recruit under their
wing like men and black one it's not
really like that
that's it Thompson wants to take us
seriously so you'll always have that
dynamic of the one who takes it more
seriously than the other one it carries
on the traditions of men and blacks is
essentially mission impossible or James
Bond's but with aliens no I think it's
knew enough to be a proper fourth movie
which doesn't really tie into the other
ones though there are references in here
I thought that was pretty cool funny
enough men and blacks had that thing
we're sick all right they're looking for
something they have to get their hands
on something before someone else gets
their hand on that something so really
it's the quest for merchandise women in
black is so this is no different in that
sense but the other men in black movies
had an antagonist they had a face of
danger this one doesn't really I mean
there are a couple of dudes coming after
them and they have really awesome powers
but no personality the two baddies going
after them reminded me of those two
ghost guys from the Matrix Reloaded I
mean they're cool they do cool things
just no personality I got to go in a new
direction and by the end I found it fine
I like it when men and black movies had
antagonists with personality and just
when the movie starts to feel stale and
predictable they do a couple things for
you're like oh this is actually deeper
than the other man in black movies I
took that I liked that a lot
and the side characters this is little
dude his name's Pawnee pawnees awesome
there was one moment I thought was a
really stupid moment just kind of I'm
gonna compare because of men and black
one I can't think of a moment like that
is it for that scene when Will Smith's
character was brand new and use like hey
what does this do and he touches that
ball and that ball just bounces all
around the headquarters such a wrecking
things it's like that times about a
billion they're literally like hey
here's this thing what do we do I don't
know
push a button I was like we've
established it could be very dangerous
you don't know what it why would you do
that this your first day isn't it like
bosey yeah I thought that was a really
dumb moment in the world where I just
word vomit my reviews I'm glad I
remembered right here right now to tell
you about it because in the end men in
black international it's what I wanted
from a new men in black movie it's fun
it has charms they have charm they have
charisma together it's a solid kinda
fresh and kinda new but not really new
take on a franchise that's not really
that new in the end I lack I smiled I
had a good time at the movie theater
that's what a movie like this supposed
to give me good time in fact it was a
good time no alcohol required alright so
men in black international have you seen
it what do you think about it or what's
your favorite to least favorite men in
black movies I know ranking movies
pretty fun right why not I keep it going
I gotta fix it hold on these things are
important and if you like this video if
you can click that like button as you've
been doing it helps me out it helps a
video it helps the channel out and I
love you for all of it and I love you
even if you don't understand it helps I
appreciate it and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]